Pat Fallon of Texas with us he's a
member of the House oversight and armed
services committee and thank you for
taking a little time out of your
Thanksgiving Day a weekend this long
weekend to join us to talk about this
very important topic and this one that's
so critical to your state let's just
start with your thoughts the back and
forth McCarthy calling for mayorchist to
resign or face potential impeachment and
from the standpoint of DHS that's not
happening
well Molly thanks for having me on and
well you know they just said that he
inherited this problem by orcas okay so
let's just look at the numbers and look
at some data in this April there were
234 000 illegal border crossings that
was the worst month we had ever had that
was 1258 percent worse than the last
April that President Trump had been in
office and then in May it was 241 000
illegal border crossings which was 930
worse than the last May president Trump
was in office so clearly Joe Biden's
Administration has made this issue about
10 times worse we've had eight months in
a row of over 200 000 illegal border
crossings and what Joe Biden's policies
have done Molly is made every state of
border state you know one of the other
big issues we've been watching ongoing
the Biden Administration has now been
ordered by a federal judge to stop using
title 42. that's slated to end now
December 21st to turn away immigrants
cut illegally at our Southern border
related to health policy are you
concerned that this ongoing crisis is
about to get far far worse
yes and Molly you took the words right
out of my mouth it's not even a crisis
anymore it's an absolute catastrophe
it's my good friend Tony Gonzalez just
said and the last bit you had up there
because I mean look at just what's
happening with the illegal narcotics the
Mexican drug cartels are controlling our
Southern border not the federal
government and this is asymmetrical
Warfare we lost 107 000 Americans last
year that this Administration doesn't
mention ever to opioid overdoses 80 000
of those from fentanyl alone and most of
the fentanyl is produced in China so we
lost 293 Americans a day in World War II
we lost 297 a day so this is
asymmetrical Warfare being waged by the
Chinese Communists and nobody's saying
anything about it and we have to change
course yeah you know you're bringing
attention to how this is all across the
country an issue that's being affected
all across the country Christina Coleman
showing us those buses of migrants
arriving in Pennsylvania today and now
Republican Attorneys General from 15 GOP
led states are fighting to keep title
42. I mean this is from Alaska to Kansas
to West Virginia they have submitted an
emotion to U.S District Judge Emmett
Sullivan to intervene they argue that if
title 42 is terminated there will be
this increased release of aliens and
will flow to other states we're already
seeing the buses going around the
country and that this will be a
financial burden on the states that will
eventually be hosting them your thoughts
do the AGS have a case here and do they
have a chance of succeeding
well I certainly hope so because we've
already seen 5 million illegal border
crossings when you consider when you
count the encounters we've had plus the
known godaways under the Biden
Administration that is a colossal amount
and the border patrol agents tell us
they can only handle up to 5 000 illegal
crossers a day and now we're looking
already Molly at about twice that and if
title 42 or sorry title 42 article 40
goes away then we're looking at an
absolute flood that'll be unstoppable
because this Administration refuses to
have to Institute the weight in Mexico
policy which president Trump did which
said if you're claiming claiming Asylum
you have to wait Mexico while we
adjudicate your case
uh House GOP leader Kevin McCarthy made
that recent trip down to the Border he
is trying to walk this path with the
name to become speaker facing a few
bumps in the road recently a fifth
Republican lawmaker has now announced
opposition representative Ralph Norman
of South Carolina he's joining some of
the other you know rather more vocal
opponents to like Congressman Matt Gates
of Florida for instance you know and if
the current margins hold Republicans
they only have about a four vote
majority and that's pretty tight what do
you think it means for Kevin McCarthy as
he aims for this ascent
well you know the rules are in our GOP
conference state that we're going to
have nominees and we have our own
internal debates discussions and then we
vote and Kevin McCarthy won that vote
188 to 31. and so he is now our nominee
and I don't want the Democrats to have
any say whatsoever and who the next
speaker is we certainly didn't have any
say you know when Nancy Pelosi was I was
elected so uh I you know it's well time
will tell but Kevin McCarthy is the one
we do have the majority now he led us to
that majority and he also went around
the country for the last two years
racing hundreds of millions of dollars
for candidates to ensure that we could
defeat Nancy Pelosi and retire her once
and for all are you concerned about
those tight margins
no yeah sure I mean I would have been
you know Molly if we had done three
percent better we would have had 24 more
reps so the the Red Wave almost hit it
didn't quite hit unfortunately is we'd
have 245 but instead it looks like we're
gonna have 222. so you know in every
vote if we lose five we don't win so
it's going to be we have to really unite
and hold together as a conference and
and do you think that means we're going
to see a lot of power in some of the
more moderate members of your party
you know I hope that the conservatives
you know rule the day I've talked to
Kevin McCarthy so has many others about
we need to be painting with bold colors
not soft pastels we need to take a book
out of you know Ronald Reagan take a
book out of Donald Trump and really you
know listen to the people that got us
here and do what's in the best interest
of this country yeah Red Wave or not
it's going to be pretty interesting uh
we really appreciate your Insight thank
you so much Pat Fallon congressman from
Texas uh for sharing a little bit of
your time with us this Thanksgiving
weekend thanks Molly God bless hey it's
Will Kane click here to subscribe to the
Fox News Channel on YouTube it's the
best way to get our latest interviews
and highlights and click to subscribe to
the will Kane podcast for full episodes
right now